I never did drugs growing up I maybe did
pot once or twice and found it slowed me
down to the point of I never wanted to
do it again and just sort of Walled that
whole thing off as I don't know stuff
that other people do mhm and then during
Co I read the body keeps the score MH
and you know I had struggled with some
things from my entire life in terms of
anxiety and and just getting stuck in
kind of ruts of feeling and it was 2021
January where I just remember talking
about follow the
flow I stood up went to my computer I
remember being in Miami at my parents
house
Googling ketamine treatment New York
City I knew nothing about ketamine like
nothing how was it even in your field
just popped into the head I don't know I
just remember going ketamine there in
New York
City calling up scheduling the
consultation and a week later I'm in
back in New York going to to meet the
doctor and I was like I don't know if
I'm right for this I don't want anything
that will mess with my creativity I said
the only reason I'm entertaining this
idea is because it's in a doctor's
office I said I would never do drugs on
my own because the fear surrounding that
of what could happen and what the where
it's procured from and all that stuff
would end up infecting the whole
experience and with a doctor's office
you know I'm entertaining it I said but
I don't want it to affect my creativity
I don't want it to he's like it's only
going to make you more yourself and more
creative but he goes these are the three
things that I think make for a good
candidate he's like number
one have you felt emotionally numb for
most of your life and at that point in
my life absolutely I think I was in a
just cycles of numbness number two was
did you have a volatile childhood where
emotions were not particularly welcome
and I was like check
check check in number three he goes this
one's the most important he's like do
you know how to have
fun and I said no and I cried I remember
crying in the office he's like do you
know how to have fun and I was the first
time anyone had asked the the question
in the right way cuz I knew the idea fun
I knew that I should be having fun I
knew how to act like I was having fun
but I never felt like I was having fun
and he's like and he goes you don't
drink I said no and he goes and I
meditate I was that point four five
years into meditation he's like you're
going to have a very good response to
this he just like instantly and so I
started ketamine
treatments at that time I think you do
six and 12 days and then you go back for
a booster in my case it's every 10 weeks
and I still go and it changed my life I
mean it was like I feel like a totally
different person because of those cuz
what it did is it woke up parts of my
brain that I didn't know existed because
they had shut off so early but I didn't
know they were there and then all of a
sudden I started to get glimpses of what
I could be like you know and then it
became a question of could I hold on to
that and little by little over some
people I think get their benefits much
quicker or they don't get any benefits
at all I mean it's so individual in my
case it was almost like a practice it
was like every 10 weeks I'd go learn a
million things work on those things in
between go back and it almost became
like my version of like the deepest
therapy you know and I think it's become
it's become a
huge just reason for everything and I
think it's also allowed me to follow the
flow more than ever because the whole
thing of of aine treatment is it's a
sedative right so it puts your brain in
such a relaxed state that you have no
choice but to follow the flow where it
goes theow usually leads you closer to
the truth so I don't know I think it's
for someone who was so
anti-drugs there was the biggest thing
I've changed my mind about
yeah